bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre édition s'y occuper vos enfants
pendant les vacances est un véritable
casse tête avec lucie sauvageau du musée
de la vie nous tenterons de vous
apporter quelques idées d'activités du 6
au 9 novembre le théâtre de saint
quentin présente
ubu roi mise en scène par declan
donnellan nicolas gervais a rencontré
sylvain levitte
l'un des protagonistes chaque semaine le
septième art est mis à l'honneur dans
notre chronique cinéphiles grégory
pagano responsable de l'espace philippe
noiret clayes-sous-bois nous livre son
coup de coeur j'ai rien à faire je
m'ennuie ici cette douce mélodie résonne
à vos oreilles chers parents ou
grands-parents qui vous occuper de vos
petits anges pendant les enfants les
enfants pardon les vacances sachez que
le musée da ville propose des animations
tous les après midi du mercredi au
samedi et pour en parler ce soir l'uci
sauvageau bonsoir
alors vous êtes la responsable de
l'action culturelle du musée
pouvez vous nous dire déjà dans un
premier temps qu'elles sont d'une
manière générale les objectifs de ces
ateliers
alors l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'apprendre ensemble
de s'intéresser de sensibiliser au cadre
de vie de chacun et plus
particulièrement patrimoine à
l'urbanisme en général alors ce sont des
ateliers plutôt pédagogique
on y apprend des choses on y crée des
choses c'est ludique comme on dit c'est
un mot un peu à la mode cellule
exactement les enfants viennent c'est à
dire que les parents déposent des
enfants et puis ils sont tous seuls
pourquoi leurs zones d'ombré lutte c'est
vraiment qu'il ya un échange entre
générations entre parents et enfants ou
autres aux grands parents et l'enfant et
améliorant parents qui accompagnent
aussi et que le l'atelier se
construisent vraiment avec les enfants
et les parents dont convient milliards
au moins un adulte il a serré c'est un
moment des changes c'est un moment
d'échangé enfin un peu privilégiés
justement en famille alors vous avez
construit en fait ces ateliers autour de
deux thématiques
la première c'est le plastique et le
design puisque c'est en lien avec
l'exposition qui est actuellement
présentée et c'est également une
thématique d'urbanisme alors à dire
comment c'était avec le plastique nos
jeunes en fugue vont pouvoir se glisser
dans la peau de designers de quoi il
s'agit et comment se déroule cet atelier
qu'on appelle d'ailleurs l'atelier
désigne des zain pardon ancien jordan
son siège c'est un atelier où les
enfants sont invités à parcourir un
petit peu dans l'exposition pour voir
différents exemples de mise en oeuvre du
plastique dans le design et puis ensuite
de d'imiter eux mêmes les designers et
de créer un siège design est on
fonctionne différentes contraintes
telles que des vrais designer là vous
leur fait visiter d'abord l'exposition
vouloir expliquer un petit peu l'origine
aussi du plastique son évolution
peut-être à travers l'histoire
oui on leur explique ce que c'est que le
plastique d'abord parce que c'est pas
évident et puis ensuite un petit peu son
histoire comment on fabrique du
classique et puis quels sont les progrès
techniques qui permettent d'obtenir des
différentes pièces de design qu'on peut
voir dans l'exposition phare justement
nous avons rencontré certains de ces
enfants qui ont particules participé cet
après midi donc à cet atelier
on va écouter ce qu'ils ont retenu
en train de faire une chaise et non
c'est nous qui la payons en cartons
ayant carte on l'apprendra la créer nous
mêmes mais a pris pour qu'eux aussi le
placer ça peut avoir un peu aussi faire
avec des affaires comme ça fait en
plastique et le plastique ça peut être
dans n'importe quel objet commun les
fraudeurs
tout ça et j'adore parce que des
contrats grosses chaussures et je
pourrais prendre le plastique pour faire
des choses or voilà apparemment le
plastique c'est fantastique ça crée des
vocations en tout cas donc cet atelier
design ton siège à une autre version
pour les plus grands un peu plus grand à
partir de 12 ans partir de 12 ans
jusqu'à 18 ans c'est vraiment pour les
adolescents alors qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire et c'est la même chose
alors non c'est pas la même chose c'est
un atelier où vraiment on invite les
adolescents à monter leur propre agence
il a peut se faire seul ou en équipe
et là ils font vraiment tout le
processus de fabrication d'un objet
design c'est à dire du dessin qui est le
premier geste designer jusqu'à la
modélisation puis le prototype la
maquette de l'object pour qu'il reparte
là aussi avec quelques choses repartent
avec leur leurs prototypes leurs
maquettes et puis par contre on la prend
en photo avant qu'il l'emmène chez eux
ils peuvent participer au jeu concours
design et c'est gagné qui a un jeu
concours sur facebook et qui leur permet
de gagner éventuellement la modélisation
de leurs objets sur une imprimante 3d
alors cet atelier aura lieu notamment
vendredi à 15 heures donc au musée de la
ville
pour ceux qui souhaitent s'inscrire
parce qu'il faut s'inscrire il faut
s'inscrire tous les ateliers sont sur
réservation
donc rendez vous sur le site internet du
musée de la ville pour toutes les
inscriptions ou par téléphone iphone
d'accord parce que votre spécificité
donc vous atteler les ateliers du musée
de la ville c'est qu'on apprend c'est
qu'on pratique donc en fait voilà il ya
la fois cette découverte et ses
manipulations
alors quand il va s'agir là du thème de
l'urbanisme par exemple à saint quentin
qu'est ce que les enfants vont apprendre
l'atelier par exemple je prends celui du
sculptures dans la ville donc c'est
plutôt contemporain qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui est plutôt contemporain s'est auto v
de la mise en oeuvre de l'art dans
l'espace public la saint quentin en
yvelines ya énormément d'oeuvre d'art
dans l'espace public
donc on leur montre sur maquette des
exemples de d'oeuvre qui sont installés
dans l'espace public
on leur explique ce que c'est ce qu'elle
représente pourquoi on les a mis là et
puis ensuite ils sont invités à eux même
inventé
non pas reproduire ça il faut vraiment
qu'ils créent leurs propres oeuvres le
but aussi c'est de les faire créer
imaginer et c'est une oeuvre monumentale
c'est-à-dire à échelle humaine qui
doivent pour laquelle doivent prendre en
compte les contraintes d'un
environnement donné dans lequel ils
doivent installer cette heure alors
c'est u c'est un travail collectif là où
individuel ça peut être collectif sur
les ateliers familiaux comme ça de
vacances souvent les enfants aiment
créer leur propre lorsque tout à fait
possible s'ils veulent se regrouper
c'est aussi absolument permis d'accord
et l'atelier c'est béton alors c'est
béton il s'agit de comprendre comment on
fabrique du béton et de créer un bloc de
béton décoré alors décoré soit de
différentes couleurs soit avec
différents matériaux avancés toujours
sur le même principe en une découverte
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
donc on va dans le quartier saint
quentin pour voir différentes
différentes mises en oeuvre du béton sur
différents bâtiments
et puis ensuite au musée il crès ce bloc
de béton d'accord donc ils repartent à
aussi avec avec un échantillon de leur
échantillon de béton qu'ils auront créé
combien coûtent ces ateliers il coûte 3
euros par participant
d'accord il ya un tarif réduit pour les
gens qui ont la carte famille du musée
des carrés à 2 euros
alors vos enfants vont pouvoir également
se glisser dans la peau de paysagiste
alors là encore une fois de quoi il a
encore une fois c'est toujours sur le
thème donc de l'urbanisme a cette fois
vu par les espaces verts et on les
enfants sont invités à se mettre dans la
peau de paysagistes et à créer une
maquette des espaces verts en prenant en
compte les différentes circulation les
différents mobiliers qu'on peut y
trouver à créer cette maquette d'un
jardin imaginaire qui serait réalisable
est ce que vous vous leur mettez à
disposition comme
avec différents matériaux très simple du
papier du carton du sable coloré des
épices également des choses végétales
des pots pourris des chocolats pour
faire les arbres et ils construisent
comme ça une maquette colorée
bon bah tout cas c'est riche divers en
activité de poids donc vraiment occupé
les enfants donc jusque jusqu'à samedi
donc de la semaine prochaine donc encore
une fois rendez vous sur le site
internet pour voir le déroulé du
programme puisque c'est du mercredi au
samedi
lucie merci beaucoup d'être remercions
plateau dokui vous remercie alors on
continue toujours dans les activités
donc pour les enfants cette fois ci nous
partons au scarabée à la verrière les
enfants ont découvert une activité
musicale les percussions retour sur cet
atelier d'initiation plutôt rythmée
voyages aux quatre coins du monde à la
dernière durant deux jours l'espace aimé
césaire accueille des enfants de 7 à 15
ans pour des ateliers percussions au
programme la batucada ce genre de
musique brésilien aux proches de la
samba se jouent avec des instruments
utilisés lors des carnavals
dans un tout autre style à quelques
mètres de là certains s'initie à la
tradition africaine du djembé retour
dans les années 20 aux caraïbes
ici on joue du steel drum un cierge
explique qu'une histoire de cet
instrument l'un des seuls exemples de
révolution par la musique les anglais
ils ont envahi les îles et que les
habitants ils ont été tous tués et
subsistent en esclavage pouvait plus
faire de musique alors ils ont trouvé
des bidons et ils ont ils ont qu'à
bosser ça fait cet instrument fabriqué à
partir de bidons de pétrole est
accessible à tous et ne nécessite aucune
connaissance musicale l'enseignement et
orale on n'a pas partition rien du tout
les notes sont indiquées sur les
instruments et puis ben voilà c'est la
mémoire qui va travailler et puis
l'apprentissage de l'oreille direct
il n'y a pas de partition est laissé
entre eux celui qui guide le professeur
et puis les élèves qui font qu'ils vont
se servir de oc de leurs propres moyens
des camarades et essayer à chaque fois
d'avoir quelque chose de cohérent
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux propose
également aux enfants des activités
cette fois ci c'est d'imiter les petits
mexicain on regarde pour la toussaint
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux rente
hommage à ses morts à la mode mexicaine
traditionnelle en amérique centrale la
fête des morts célèbres en famille les
ancêtres disparus
malgré son nom c'est une fête joyeuse
les mariachis viennent jouer de la
musique dans les maisons décorées de
fleurs et ont relevé au squelette leurs
plus beaux habits encore aussi des têtes
de mort comme ce matin dans cet atelier
et les enfants se montrent créatif avec
leurs crânes en terre cuite géant prenez
le pain tout en blanc je vais jetter un
de bouche jaune
des motifs orange et bleu c'est une
initiative qui a été prise par
l'estaminet de célébrer la fête des
morts un peu autrement et de donner une
connotation et keane à notre accès à une
autre culture qui était la culture
mexicaine
il ya une exposition frida kahlo en ce
moment à paris et donc on avait envie
envie de faire un lien par rapport àça
ouvrir un peu les gens ici sur l'autre
dimension culturelle car les dimensions
habituel jusqu'à vendredi les enfants
auront l'occasion de découvrir cette
fête méconnu via d'autres ateliers
créatifs crâne en sucre peint des morts
et projection d'un film sur le thème
viendront agrémenter leur culture
mexicaine alors les vacances c'est aussi
l'occasion de visiter des expositions
celle d'andré le nôtre en perspective
présentée jusqu'au 24 février au château
de versailles
au delà du jardinier bien connu c'est
également l'homme son art et son
influence qui sont illustrés au travers
de documents inédits présentés pour la
première fois l'image de jonathan
wiedemann
les visiteurs s'attendent à découvrir
andré le nôtre
le paysagiste le jardinier du roi c'est
aussi une autre vision de l'homme de sa
carrière et la diversité de son art que
célèbrent le château de versailles à
travers l'exposition un vrai le nôtre en
perspective jusqu'au 24 février pour
clôturer l'hommage rendu tout au long de
l'année au 400e anniversaire de la
naissance d'andré le nôtre
exposition se présente comme bouquet
final on pense toujours à andré le dos
des perspectives asymétrie alors que ça
existait avant lui dont pâtit la portée
et c'est ce qu'il a apporté qui vraiment
le coeur de la matière de cet de cette
exposition où tout le monde croit
connaître en or est le nôtre
mais au delà du jardinier bien connu du
dessinateur de jardin le paysagiste
l'aménageur
d'un espace immense et bien c'est
également le contrôleur général des
bâtiments l'homme proche du roi
l'immense collectionneurs jamais une
exposition consacrée andré le nôtre a
présenté une telle variété et richesse
de pièces sont rassemblés pour la
première fois et chef-d'oeuvre de sa
collection personnelle peinture bronzé
médaille des documents de sa main qui
révèle certains de ces projets et
réalisations inattendue après avoir
découvert cette carrière et ses grandes
réalisations découvrir cinq salles
consacrées à son art sur les grandes
perspectives les découverts les couverts
entrer dans l'atelier de le nôtre
comment ils aménagent leur tous ceux du
territoire et et enfin la modernité de
le nôtre ça nous donne des choses pas
très différente des univers différents
on entre dans l'intimité des bosquets où
on ressort à la lumière de la suite de
lenôtre quoi après sa mort est donc cet
héritage un héritage qui est multiple
qui est à faire en france et en europe
une exposition unique qui suscite
émotion et surprise devant des documents
inédits à découvrir jusqu'au 24 février
notez également que ce soir sur france 3
à 20h35 l'émission des racines et des
ailes sera consacrée à lenôtre
retrouvons sans plus attendre nicolas
gervais pour sa chronique dans le
kiosque
cette semaine nicolas nous fait
découvrir la pièce ubu roi présenté au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
toulouse pelé à ubu roi le texte
d'alfred jarry est bien le génialissime
metteur en scène britannique declan
donnellan nous le donne à voir dans un
salon parisien du 6 au 9 novembre
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour nous ont parlé le jeune comédien
sylvain levitte sortie du conservatoire
en 2012 et qui a déjà joué donc deux
fois avec dokhan de nolan et avec denis
podalydès
c'est maintenant c'est tout de suite
jonathan vois ça doit fois n'en vois ça
jubile jules mais c'est fini c'est
l'histoire de deux paires ubu et mary
but qui veulent accéder au pouvoir
mary but un site père ubu à tuer le roi
venceslas et à prendre le trône et à
partir du moment où il devient roi et va
se mettre à tuer tous les nobles tous
les magistrats tous les financiers de
son royaume
ça c'est la version jarry jarry a écrit
donc en étant adolescent et il a utilisé
deux pièces directement référence à son
professeur de physique
monsieur hébert et il a il a fait une
caricature grossière de son professeur
de physique
si décriée par se battre
et l'on sa part m
et rentable dans la musique
et mon casque finances les 23 cas
finances
les droits
il
là
declan donnellan a pris vraiment au pied
de la lettre l'esprit de la pièce de
jarry c'est à dire qu'il s'est vraiment
dit il s'est vraiment mis dans l'esprit
de jarry est d'essayer de construire une
pièce qui répondent directement à l'envi
d'alfred jarry au moment où elle a été
écrite
donc comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'était vraiment une une caricature et
qui nous provocation vis-à-vis du monde
adulte visa me vis-à-vis du monde donc
de son professeur de physique et donc il
s'est emparé véritablement de cette
pièce en la mettant aujourd'hui dans un
appartement parisien
bourgeois et regarde toute la pièce de
jarry à travers le regard d'un
adolescent donc c'est moi qui
interprètent cet adolescent là il
regarde toute la pièce de jarry à
travers ce point de vue là comme si cet
adolescent qui est donc du coup ou par
métaphore un peu alfred jarry se se
moque et dévoile le véritable
comportement de ses parents le véritable
comportement on peut tout savoir
après un mauvais jour
des comportements qu'on a tous le désir
de pouvoir
l'image qu'on a un public n'est pas
l'image qu'on l'a en privé aussi et même
pour soi même parfois mais c'est
profondément humain cette mise en scène
la et profondément humaine et humaine
dans toutes ses contradictions c'est à
dire que on cache en permanence désir de
pouvoir de pouvoir absolu
à travers ces ce masque de la
civilisation
declan donnellan dans les répétitions
nous a dit qu'on a tous un ubu en nous
on a tous enfin on a tous des désirs de
pouvoir on a tous des désirs de deux
meurtres plus ou moins assumée
là cet adolescent s'est passé à l'acte
dévoile cette chose-là et révèlent
qu'ils n'ont pas la véritable identité
mais ce qu'on a tous en nous qu'on cache
vous trouvez qu'il me paraît sophie
sendra celui ci depuis combien de temps
on est têtu débarbouiller ignorer drôle
voilà
m mais qu'est ce que vous faites mais
met en garde il a encore dû changer les
idées laissez moi je vous en prie faut
plus que je ne sais pas faire je vous ai
pas tous deux personnages au moins dans
cette pièce comprenait six comédiens et
à l'intérieur de ça on joue tous les
personnages de la pièce d'ubu roi et on
a six personnages principaux de la pièce
d'ubu roi p révu mary but capitaine
bordure le roi venceslas la reine
heureusement des bougres la cdci
personnages principaux de la pièce d'ubu
roi et à côté de ça on a tous on sait
tous créer des identités parallèle donc
pour le pour le dîner bourgeois tout ce
qui se passe dans cet appartement et
donc du coup on a le pearl en permanence
tout le jeu en fête se passe de on passe
de quelque chose de très lisse et très
propre à quelque chose de profondément
dégueulasse et très viscéral et très
primitif
on a fait des improvisations justement
sur le sur le deux rapports dans le
dîner bourgeois donc ça a été des
improvisations qu'on a fait pendant
pendant plusieurs semaines sur voilà
comment est ce qu'on établit cette base
là à partir de laquelle ubu peut sortir
ses rues but vient de quelque chose et
ubu est une réaction à quelque chose et
après donc à l'intérieur de ça c'était
tout le fantasme adolescents c'est à
dire de savoir comment est ce qu'un
adolescent peut voir par exemple une
scène de conspiration c'est d'essayer de
trouver l'esprit de jarry et d'essayer
de trouver l'esprit dans lequel jarry
lui même a écrit cette pièce au moment
où il l'a écrite avec le droit le projet
enterré
si chambéry bo
voilà
et voilà donc eu lui roi c'est au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
6 au 9 novembre et en sorte que cette
situation ubuesque pour retrouver le
doubs plateau d'aurélia merci nicolas
sachez que vous êtes le bienvenu pour
venir sur le doubs plateau du kiosque
passons tout de suite à la chronique
cinéphiles
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d' elodie
moines
c'est beaucoup d'émotions fortes c'est
très réussi
belle image c'est ce que j'attendais en
fait c'est le film du siècle
j'avais la boule au ventre tout le long
du film c'est incroyable ça allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir
tout paraît totalement réaliste c'est
tout à fait bloquant ainsi génial
après c'était très impressionnant
vraiment se croit dans l'espace et moi
qui ai le vertige et bien j'ai eu peur
plusieurs fois un vraiment oui oui c'est
très bien c'est les mêmes films que
j'avais vu j'avais vu le coeur des
hommes
1 le coeur d un bond de france à elle
voulait voir les corps de trois c'était
toujours aussi bien un très bon film
ça détend pas fidèle au coeur des hommes
2 la suite voilà très bien très bon cru
c'est une excellent de bout en bout
je trouvais film très bien je pensais
pas que j'avais vu que c'était une
comédie mais je pensais pas que c'était
vraiment une comédie en fait c'est une
comédie un peu noir mais vraiment une
comédie et j'ai passé un très bon moment
c'est un un bon film de luc besson comme
d'habitude jamais déçu la chronique
cinéphiles comme vous savez c'est aussi
l'occasion d'entendre un professionnel
du cinéma nous donner son coup de coeur
cette fois ci c'est au tour de grégory
pagano responsable de l'espace philippe
noiret aux clayes sous bois
nous proposons une séance de rattrapage
à l'espace philippe loiret avec le
dernier film de woody allen blood jasmin
les a sorti un petit peu plus d'un mois
et commencent à disparaître des écrans
commerciaux mais nous continuons à
diffuser parce que pour nous c'est
vraiment un gros coup de coeur est avec
un rythme des sorties d'une fois par an
au dilemme c'est parfois des bons crus
des moins bon cru cette année c'est
vraiment un très bon cru ce film avec
sans doute l'un des meilleurs films
peut-être même de toute sa carrière
c'est un film qui reprendra tous les
thèmes chers au maître de la comédie
musicale a été qu'est ce qu'on
retrouvera les questions existentielles
l'amour la vie la mort mais on a tout ça
sur un fond de scandales financiers donc
et très actuel ça permettra d'ailleurs
aux personnes qui ne connaissent pas
l'univers de woody allen de découvrir et
de pourquoi pas s'initier d'une très
bonne façon au contraire ceux qui sont
déjà fans et bien on en a comme toujours
les pro et les anti et je dois quand
même noter la participation ci est
blanche et vraiment extraordinaire avec
une partition de très haut niveau qui a
joué dans ce personnage de jasmin vous
laissera vraiment pas indifférent et 6
vous emmène avec beaucoup d'empathie sur
quelqu'un qui est pourtant départ tout à
fait antipathique et c'est donc cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret le
film blood jasmin de woody allen
si vous manque encore quelques idées
pour occuper vos enfants pendant les
vacances voici encore quatre lieux
peut-être auquel vous pourrez vous
rendre tout d'abord à rambouillet la
bergerie nationale propose une animation
autour des cowboys et des indiens
au programme tir à l'arc à la carabine
création d'amulettes étoile de shérif
donc fonction de quel côté vous allez
vous situez rodéo à cheval mécanique
recherche de pépites d'or enfin tout
enfant déguisé bénéficiera d'un tarif
réduit
du côté de versailles au château partez
à la découverte de parcours en famille
des ateliers
là par contre l'inscription est
obligatoire au château de breteuil donc
cette fois ci c'est à choisel jusqu'au 3
novembre différentes activités séances
de contes jeux piste atelier feuilles
d'automne sont également au programme
et enfin à poissy le musée du jouet
propose également différentes animations
jusqu'au 3 novembre des ateliers
initiation cinéma d'animation
fabrication de doudou l'a également
l'inscription est obligatoire n'hésitez
pas à vous y rendre en notre édition est
à présent terminé merci de nous avoir
suivi sur téléfilm je vous retrouve
mercredi prochain en direct à 18h30
d'ici là profitez de toutes les sorties
culturelles possible sur notre
territoire à mercredi